[Musik]
naja und junge ja freunde ist richtig
ich sehe nämlich aus wie scheiße da
zählt es ist ja dass mal wieder im blog
auf dem kanal gekommen ist aber jetzt
ist ja ich könnte hier das kasseler ist
eigentlich ist der den ich meine letzten
block planen habe freunde ist soviel
passiert ich habe zum beispiel eine
elektrische zahnbürste glaub das war gar
keine so gute idee
ja okay es war dumm gesagt habe und
ehrlich gesagt ich hatte die hoffnung
dass wenn ich denke was halt doch gerade
dass ich keine wende nicht machbar habe
ja wie viele die eigentlich eine
boxershort freunde der steht einfach
lucio trauben und fassbar heraus
entscheiden einfach jetzt schon übels
kasten sondern über meinen mann
schneiden alter kraft diese
wetterveränderungen
drach gelaufen ich habe jetzt gar nicht
erst an meine sachen hier fertig gepackt
und jetzt muss ich erst mal kurz auf klo
von mittlerweile wird es richtig eng mit
dem flieger ich bin so fange ich mich
nach oben
dann brauchen sie zum flughafen quasi 25
sie schaffen sich zufällig in 15 minuten
ich habe mit frank schildt gepasst
haltung nicht abzuholen das haben wir
schon heute
wir haben 7er bmw
die besten felgen
damit das sind okay
das beste team
luca danken denn hier
ja was irgendwie nach wien bisher werden
dienen zum dritten mal in folge jedes
jahr immer in wien folgen
also ist das schon wieder quasi bewegen
doch doch ich erinnere mich ganz genau
wie alle im bus auf dich gewartet haben
da seht ihr lokal wie er mal wieder
nicht stehen bleiben
[Applaus]
doch gar nicht gesprochen warum ich
eigentlich hier bin und zwar ist die von
game changer messe die letzten beiden
jahre war ich auch schon hier auf der
messe und auch bei einem fantreffen und
diesmal war aber nur ein ganz kleines
fantreffen also sehr gemütlich wenn auch
nicht auf und am karten mit einer sonder
einfach noch leben
bilder machen dann finde ich einfach
viel sympathischer kühler
und jetzt will ich erstmal interview bei
mir
ich habe meine freunde in dieser kämen
da vorne da sieht man irgendwas sinnvoll
finde ich schon die angekommen und haben
jetzt gerade walter rosenkranz und jetzt
waren wir ja und ich in jedem stadt zum
schnitzelessen die arme katze da vorne
darf nicht in den supermarkt wir haben
ja dankeschön zum taxifahrer gesagt und
sie dachte dass ich die meine nein serie
die größe dieser karte ist einfach
abnormal freunde das ist meine hand
vergleicht man mit teleskopen das ist
wir sind übrigens schnitzel essen im
restaurant stern
hier sind stars freut sich auch
schnitzel einfach mal komplette können
freunde unterstützen rein pfeifen kann
es etwas schöneres geben heute für
meinen blog oder instagram pushen
ich heiße laser luca laser laser luca
[Musik]
ich arbeite immer ich bin einfach dieser
vorne steht möchte foto mit dir machen
wirklich
johnson video
schade
instagram luca
folgen
[Musik]
das eine frage die mich sehr dass so
etwas in köln es ist für köln ist eine
stadt die eigentlich gar nicht mal von
der architektur her so schön ist aber
die menschen sind sehr sehr sehr selten
schon sehr
deswegen möglichst schnell zu geben das
ist die nächste frage du jemals
gestalten lassen
auch nicht so groß bin
mit 190 personen immer in meinen dienst
so klein und alle fragen nicht immer
wenn sie mich nicht warum das risiko ist
wie kommst du deine video ideen auf dem
klo
die internet was ist denn sie sind und
warum mein lieblings zählt ja ich möchte
wissen liebesszenen
mein lieblings 10 hat sich für sein
lieblings cd ist am linken fuß sowie
sowie der finger ist länger oder könnte
die eigene krise angeht sehe ich sage
dass ich immerhin 10
[Musik]
anlagen informieren
ich habe letztes mal bis 4 uhr im video
geschnitten von daher hab ich
dreieinhalb schon gepennt oder so nicht
übel ist tot und immer wenn ich jetzt
gerne wird allerdings beim bauch weh
weil ich gestern bauch trainiert habe
und jetzt bin ich komplett am leiden na
wie geht's dir gut zum neuen namen
angenommen wir wollten doch wieder
reingehen hier aufs festival und der
jeep von der security kommt zur st mit
dem muss ich einmal kurz ein bodycheck
machen will nämlich ist umkämpft weil er
war ein so breit wie ich aber der wollte
nur mein körper anpasst und gucken ob
ich irgendwas verbotenes haben freunde
ich finde gerade ein paar barack obama
eine rede
ich weiß nicht warum aber ich finde dass
das hier aussieht wie ein schiff ich
gebe es noch kurz auf die bühne bei dem
festival und bin dabei zum interview mit
dabei und ja wer will mich eigentlich
interview
hallo
der talk ist vorbei freunde wir fahren
jetzt in flughafen ich bin auf jeden
fall todes mühe
[Musik]
schlaf gar nicht
in seinem nur gestellt okay dass er dem
krieger nichts gefilmt habe oder soll
ich einfach der beste blocker der welt
oder wenn man die ganzen zeit geschlafen
ich war zu hause
zu hause angekommen freunde ich bin
wirklich happy ich bin todes todes todes
müde wie sonstwas jude des übrigens da
die hat kein zuhause ich gehe jetzt
duschen weil ich wie immer halt richtig
stinkt dass man jetzt weiß ich denke
dass ich mit guten nicht mehr trinke
aber irgendwie an der stelle bildchen
heutigen blog ist allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren ich bin
einfach mega mir der ganze starcom mega
cool aber auch mega anstrengend wenn
euch das ganze video gefahren hat dann
hast du einen daumen und sonst würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns morgen in einem
weiteren video wieder unter folgt auf
insgesamt
[Musik]